Yardi no man bootleg Capcom backstage
the endless summer tour with my dog
Gerald G easy listen man I remember
September of last year you did the end
of summer festival here in Tempe as you
big Sean I'm gonna say Jacobs unless
they take calls on it yeah I remember
you and I were standing there watching
Sean because he went on early and didn't
watch it Sean never be like man can bro
I saw you can [__] you sneer tonight
that's [__] stage setup yeah yeah
yeah like talk about how you feel right
now
because cuz the tour just started and
like I've seen the evolution with my own
eyes from 400 people to you know 20,000
people is it like you have to pitch
yourself yes it's a fully open up in
yourself but it's also like it is your
balance man because I've always been
very like self-aware and that keeps me
humble in a sense of like don't let your
ego get out of whack here I'm Stan or
whatever and like now that we're here I
still feel like we have so far to go you
don't understand it's like I don't want
to suddenly wake up and have it hit me
I'm saying we're doing [__] cuz I still
feel like we got ways to go and you
gotta like it if you a great moment yeah
I got Grammys to win man I got stadiums
I got arenas I got whatever so it's like
I took out my blessings I appreciate the
journey but this is my dog with me crazy
I'm saying like we're four shows in
Sweden v believe and it's like over
10,000 people every night us and
everything see and it's not like I'm
working like I'm in the bus every night
after the show you know I'm saying
trying to cook more right so now I'm
really seeing it that's right this is
real you put the work in and you can't
get here so I just wanna keep talking
you talk about putting in work obviously
the album's been on a while now great
body work I still in the rotation in the
whip for me you just put out a couple of
Records with joint with quite boiler in
the meantime how did that record come to
be how did you get up a playable and
obviously I know you guys probably run
into each other all the time in the same
song like that that goes straight to
SoundCloud you've had a few of those
have been kind of like hits with your
fans that you know but it's something
like that I could see you working
already though right right right
oh it's funny man just with what takes
and what doesn't but I just like to feed
the fast music we had that records in
there I went to mustard studio a minute
this is actually before the album came
out and we were just still making around
last minute trying to you know I'm
saying go check in with everybody see
what Buster has see what song you know
I'm saying like and just just make as
much stuff as we can so we could pick
the chocolates for the album for and we
had down we were like yo this is too far
to just be sitting here let's put this
out so yeah I just wanted to have some
new stuff out before the tour and yeah
they're taken to it so I I saw some
I have a lot of backpack wrappers as
friends on my Facebook page and someone
posted a the article that said that you
were astray more than Kendra can call
whenever yeah obviously
oh yeah yeah people like you I don't
what the [__] this [__] guy my god
don't fail yeah but but it but it's true
you've been stringing more than Kendrick
Cole and Eminem this year you have the
line on the how important white rapper
sent was a bleach hair but how does I
mean like how does that feel obviously
those are your peers you know but like
these are my idols first realtalk yeah
I'm saying it would take a lot for me to
them peers I still think but they all
your peers now it's it's crazy to think
about it that way
well ultimately you got a look at people
whose tenure their long stretch of you
understand what they've contributed to
the culture to the game the work they
put in you know I'm saying us it's crazy
as you know I've been in this for a long
time working but as far as my dent on
like I'm saying like it's really only
the last two albums that people have
started to take notice I feel like I
still got so much work to do to be in
that conversation but then I'm saying I
saw is the way I viewed myself that's
always the ambition that I've had so you
know it's crazy but um change the time
and music what you can say is it feels
very democratic it's like the powers in
the hands are people straight up you
know I'm saying that the fans dictate
you know what they what they listened to
was pop and was it's like my graduate
the grassroots thing is moved into like
that's like yourself in logic like it
started from you know these diehard fans
they all follow a kid that was you know
20,000 people talk about going on tour
logic you just put out as partly to uh
might be Tarantino which is dope but um
talk about how this Tori ball because Yo
Gotti you know in certain cities is a
[__] you know
yeah yeah just to get with your in the
south with yo gotti you know you only
here west coast wisely and of course
logic is an incredible MC makes
incredible music it's a very diverse to
where music I know that there I know you
would mediate our for last time you were
was here you were talking about you told
me here like I had yourself a lodge for
someone else
yeah a lot of your thing ended up
working out matter that come to be
what's it like being on tour with him
cuz you guys are kind of office did you
like to party little you like they have
you know sits on the bus and plays halo
I've known him for years man is great
you know it was just like the right time
to do it
it was definitely what the fans were
asking for you know my Twitter feed are
they me or Milotic we makes our lives
when I told the lies that you know after
Santa it was just like it made sense and
then as far as you know putting the rest
of it together I wanted it to feel like
a festival you know give it a diverse
acting experience nobody wants to see
you know I'm saying the same kind of
whatever like give it and you have
different it's different up and comers
and different legs with the tour that's
a little yeah yeah and then we were
really like who's here is it made of
just getting a body kills lunes think
Amaya Kodak gets a free Kodak black
Kodak yeah we wanted to just mix it up
and just give the fans an experience but
I think I supposed of a bunch of summer
tours it's like artists come together to
give them something unique to give the
fans something
and past that man I mean we're all
friends like it's not though you know
industry put together your kind of thing
it's like I've known whitey for hello yo
gotti a short sale of no logic I love
are they just make sense
so as cool as good vibes backstage man
we all kick it you know I saw the
rickrack video
yeah that's for Rick for but here's
somebody who obviously we always talk
about like your hip-hop is coming from
the bay I feel like a lot of people may
have a differentiation for life first of
all there's just a lot of diversity
musically between you know idelle and
high road yeah hit that you know saying
like that side of hip-hop's 100% like is
that honest I was like one of the most
successful who says well give us ten
time I must prove this that there yo
have you ever liked it have you ever
speaking a high road like I'm a huge fan
of from the pyro have you ever I think
the next time you let off like a
SoundCloud you should try to be devil's
I brought out there actually I brought
to allowing at out silence
that's crazy when San Francisco yeah
yeah he he came out on a skateboard
understand it was crazy
they're heading there time to like
something like dad like I feel like like
right now would be popping like ketchup
our oh my god yeah sure
outside of collaboratory family those
children
yeah they're just [__] it does take a
bounder I'm saying I want to apply on
the guy like I could eat jump on a
record you know there we all got in the
lane and then go new record really
Spears doesn't look like you know
low-key light you know but she's bad I
might have wrote me one or two out to
Britney and I was so [__] lights like
full circle you know and meter and be
asked to do distance she's a fan
it's crazy she saw that man she was like
I was like yo thank you for asking me to
do this she was like no thank you for
doing it that's one of the biggest
entertainers alive 100 second thing is
or thing I was so impressed by I was
saying the the set of your talk like the
the production of the tour is [__] I
haven't seen anything like this since
Kanye like I think like with the Ford
the pork and [__] but talk about the
creative process when you say okay we're
going to go on this tour it's going to
be the first time you do the
amphitheater stadium circuit or arena
circuit I should say what what's that
creative process like because it's it's
art in its own way absolutely
like way each like like when that Forbes
drop that I wanted it to be a spectacle
for sure that I'm sad like a big
experienced performance art you know
understand for people to come and see
something that feels larger-than-life
you know I'm saying that takes their
breath away I'm a huge tank man like
were styling my favorite artist every
place we went to and how much he's
contributed in the live music space or
cuz I'm saying he's always pushing that
envelope in signs of production inside
of the showmanship in terms of you know
like how he puts the shows together so
he's a huge influence Drake Lil Wayne is
one of the best performers ever the
weekend has a really great show so I'm
just like a team like everybody sits
down and says okay look this is you have
like a stage production yeah yeah yeah
and then they'll bring in an original
like like a sketch of an idea or
whatever and then we all kind of chisel
away at it and tell that's what we want
it to be in every department you know
I'm standing from the visuals that go on
the walls too you know I'm saying the
size of the walls and how they laid out
what they do and how they
lighting and all this [__] like we all
nerd out over that because it's like I
care about that like I care about how my
record is mixed or not care about the
play not care about we've always like is
it harder to implement those same vibes
in this atmosphere and evidence of the
future venue because you have you've
always been so good in like yeah yeah
yeah we had we were talking like the
first tour cuz like the merch booth just
like the merch area now we have the
first production we ever had we had a
neon sign custom-made things about this
big was a circle with my logo on yeah
yeah yep and it hung you know I'm saying
with some little steps they want an
interpreter families are there and it's
like that on a very miniature scale
who's like a tiny version of kind of
what it's grown into no yeah so it's
really like a philosophy thing was like
okay when given this this what I'm gonna
make out of it and give to you when
giving this this what i'ma make out of
it and configure it and give to us
defense when giving all this it's been a
dream I've been talking about arenas and
stadiums and after theaters and all this
and when I'm in little hole-in-the-wall
clubs I have to close my eyes and
imagine yeah I'm sure I don't I'm not
hearing 10,000 people spraying 20,000
people scream I'm here at 300 peoples
great it doesn't sound that loud you
know Stan it doesn't look that big so I
have to like imagine all this and it's
like now given this opportunity say
you're about to go on a summer tour you
know I'm staying with three of the most
relevant biggest are period uh you know
and I'm staying a for y'all they're
coming together to do something big
you're lucky enough to be in this
position to play last what do you do
with this opportunity I'll be dead if we
don't make the most of it straight-up
sense it's a million dollar production
game seven you were there at the NBA
Finals obviously uh I'm a LeBron guy
just come on and I know you're a Kobe
guy but my I'm a Suns fan so I've always
hated Kobe so my love to LeBron is
strictly cuz he's like the hand and I
call it my hate for the bronze cuz I
thought but but what I mean obviously
that atmosphere that was a [__] crazy
game it was it was but like how I talked
about that day and where
that's heartbreaking spine is right
there it was an emotional rollercoaster
man I'll tell you that cuz I'm like my
manager G Robertson he's like bro good
friends from the bronze man and it were
Kobe's manager he's just he's a Jedi
Master
Rashad he's plugged in our sense so he
surprised me tonight before I think I
was going like seven
that's all he texts me it was seven I
was like you gotta be kidding me I saw
your ass going you don't say yeah yeah
yeah we're there and it's a good game
just amazing forgive me and I'm all like
I'm gonna die our basketball fan and you
know I'm saying when Golden State will
go out five or six points you know I'm
saying I'd be getting on his head and
talking about David when the brother
come back you know I'm sad and score
quick six in a row and all of a sudden
the momentum shifts he's talking [__] to
me and it was a great game all the way
down that block and that Kyrie three the
Block in the Kyrie three teams history
and that's the way it's written
are you cool with what the Warriors dude
I don't drink mommy I'm hanging out with
Shabazz and everybody and I was yeah I
was with dream on that night okay
yeah and I just told him thank you yo
man zulan has a fan lighting sense you
know we met a couple times like but I
was just like Brad this season you know
I'm saying we couldn't ask you for
anything else really you've dug deep you
gave it your all you know I'm standing
as a fan of the sport as a fan of his
team I saw you guys would talk about
obviously Donald Trump is the
the presumptive he's the nominee yeah is
a why he asked me to do a remix it [__]
down I wasn't going to bring that up
because I wasn't kind of know cause a
lot of talk about about I think yeah so
the [__] Donald Trump remix yeah yeah
yeah you hopped on this remix now listen
you know this [__] aghast it is it's
it's I love YG's idea of putting
crazy you [__] a classic Gerald move
shout out his [__] daughter
talking about to begin if there's my
cookies get it hey that's a flower I
feel like she'd be like a young pair
she'd be that she would be a fan like I
feel like she's probably like looks like
she probably is I guess their crops I
could probably still get you probably Oh
for real honest I could probably still
get it how's your mom doing man I said
your mom is out here kick it'll be 40 I
go on Instagram all the goddamn time
yeah they're real cool that's all you
make the shirt and every day they're
kindred spirits is that what it's called
yeah they're good friends
um she's good she you know she like
[__] probably two or three myself
before oh but now you [__] you're
that dude man do you notice the
difference like it's like I try not to
honestly man I really try not to love
just I can't get with the same people
I'm saying attack them with the same
people when I come it's not a short and
you still bring out traded truth yeah
absolutely and that [__] was late but
without like two came out nobody can't
go like you said I'm on your record what
did Gerald was really a vulture mm-hmm
that's some real [__] like I feel like
nobody can't ever say that about you he
will get into stuff sometimes until you
dig a little deeper and they're like not
as kids really just been in it for this
long or whatever but oh man I just want
to keep working I'm excited I got this
project I literally I just decided I was
gonna do and it's kind of back to what
first started to put me on in the first
place it was in the summer okay I'm
doing another project like that while
I'm just flipping a bunch I'm this
sapling right so this is gonna be like a
mixtape yeah so you're gonna that's my
project for the yeah I'm already two
songs in oh yeah I'm gonna second it now
yes I'm just all summer tell me all day
I'm knocking out features and I'm
working on this tape and I'm just right
yeah so you'll be I saw like boom back
John so I was gonna say so I was gonna
say bro like yes I got up like you gotta
like do officer I want to see you being
a couple really nice features oh I miss
making beats on your font and jay-z on a
[__] song or something that's that's
crazy so so so your two songs in
solution
oh yeah maybe get it by the end of the
tour absolutely absolutely
like a week or two that's what's up May
so we got a new GED project I know you
got is it a clothing line oh you go to
the merch store and it's like almost
like you got a clothing line
that's like super defined yet it's just
like you know we build it piece by piece
and if I say it's my team the guys I
remember it's the creative the
fulfillment you know I'm saying they
also run a brand great birthing circus
so they have mad experience with you
know cousin so how's it doing factories
house it hasn't great yeah yeah I say I
say look I want a black denim jacket and
I'm saying with this on the back a week
later they got a sample four minutes
cuts or the right fits you know I'm
saying when I say fresco we've got no
choice with some killer GZ coat check em
out or five dates in so there's plenty
more left
yeah how many you I know you got berries
already sold out right yeah that's gonna
be funnier than us yeah this is Chris
it's been a learning curve because it's
like like we're so used to every show
we've ever done is every time I do these
these are like amphitheaters that fit
like 30,000 people meant to so small
section generally bonfires but Carmen
they've been doing great at this door
like 15 20 based on Twitter Instagram
and the photos the ship looks so down as
young man makes you go beat the album
it's out right now hopefully they'll be
talking about Grammy nominations this
next brand new cycle will set my movies
do I feel like not a little bit you
gotta get these movies you know that's
what's next yeah I got it
you got an angel okay you got acting
publishing yeah actually I did I went
saw acting close because I wasn't like
because that's the thing I don't want to
just jump into a world without camera
spend my trying to their whole life
trying to do that so don't just jump in
you know I'm saying are cool because you
think it was my horizon yeah oh you'd be
a player's remember they wouldn't
I have respect for crap I respect for
the world so yeah yeah anyway gee I
appreciate you brother
I saw always backbone